buzzer thank you for laying out this
framework I think it's really helpful
and of the issue that I had with it
though it seems that there's maybe an
element of ethnicity demographics and so
as you know that economists MIT this and
this where it goes to your your comment
on the mounting ten of religious people
well you think about that in terms of a
socio economic standpoint it might be
that lower-income communities around the
world might need this or more mouths
intense like your comment on that and
then if you think about sort of this
smorgasbord going back to this formula
religiosity seems like only the luxury
of the Western world to be able to pick
and choose their religion I mean that's
sort of an element that seems to be
missing here so I guess I'm just like
your your comment on sort of where we
can fit each of these strands in terms
of I think in terms of Austrian
economics I think i gestured toward it
when I said smorgasbord religiosity in
the West and in a certain layer in the
in in the rest of the well that's that's
too it's not quite accurate but but but
certainly you have to have a certain you
have to be up certain at the
socioeconomic status simply to make your
point in order to engage in in this kind
of create self creation of religious
identity for yourself certain sense of
power certain sense of agency and so
forth in terms of lower level and and
socio-economic lower level interest an
embrace of religion it's it's true and
you would expect it but you know the
book that to editors of economies have
written by the title god is back which
is worth worth reading flipping through
begins with a reading group of of highly
educated a kind of Bible reading group
of highly educated folks in Shanghai and
they're in many other situations you
have high
educated young professionals core
embracing religion look at New York is a
good example if you look at somebody
like Tim Keller one of the New York
preachers right if you go to his church
average education is master's degree and
an average age 35 and it's a it's a it's
a rather influential and huge church and
you have it's replicated in any of the
metropolis that plural metropolis yes it
is thank you
London certainly their churches of this
of this sort and I think it's true also
of other what they might be feeling is
this orientation they may not feeling
they may not be feeling a sense of of
material well-being not being not will
be feeling satisfied with their material
material different but they may be
feeling that they don't have sufficient
means to organize the meaning of their
lives a sufficient strength to pursue
the life as they want to pursue the life
what they find valuable and maybe
finding in faith resources so that's our
history patients an interesting word
because you have this
visiting question I have if you look at
the Europe paradigm you have pretty
homogenous populations in Europe
historical and whereas you know you go
to the United States and it's a
pluralistic society therefore maybe
people are more religious because they
have and others who identify themselves
against or define themselves against and
so there's got to be that element that's
European geniuses maybe maybe we're
quite killed and there was a kind of
implicit peace treaty with the nation in
my conversation I was going to say that
the Pew Charitable Trusts research bears
on the question of malcontents or people
people who feel left out of
globalization the more religious there
is a middle strength correlation between
passing through the development and and
demographic transitions and decline of
average percentage of religiosity and
within countries of all levels there is
a an at least mile correlation between
lower economic status and greater
greater expressed commitment to religion
if you head there you know they're
producing huge number datasets on this
stuff and I think much of what what
you're saying is independent of the very
fine-grain thinkers and the last point
if you're
your observation about higher income
people having a sense of disorientation
to which may be a response I think
that's very important there are there is
a sense many people I think have a sense
of emptiness and the relativism that
goes with great affluence and
smorgasbord ization